نعود مره اخرى لمناقشه تطورات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا لينضم الينا من جديد من عمان
لواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك من جديد كنت بصدد
التحدث عن ما سيحدثه من تغيير تسلم
وكيف
ستواجه هذا العنصر الجديد العنصر العسكري
الجديد الذي يدخل هذه الحرب
يعني الان النظريا الجيش الروسي يمتلك 23
الف دبابه لكن السؤال الاهم ما هو مدى
المقارنه
الفعليه ومدرجه الكفاءه ما بين هذين
السلاحين اذا تحدثنا عن ابرامز او
اليوبارد مقابل دبابات الروسيه التي
تستخدم في ارض المعركه التفوق بصوره واضحه
جدا من حيث الكفاءه والقدره القتاليه
والتاثير في حجم المعركه اذا كانت معركه
تصادميه هذا هي يميل لسالح الدبابات
الغربيه لكن لا تزال هناك اوراق مخفيه لدى
روسيا لم تقدم رغم تباين التقارير الدبابه
ارماتا
نظريا تعادل ابرامز فعليا قيل في
الاختبارات انها اجتازته على ارض الواقع
لم نشاهدها تي 90 تكافئ الى حد ما والى
مستوى 80% دبابه اثنين لم نشاهدها في عرض
الميدان هل لا تزال محتفظ بها بالاحتياط
ويتم دفعها في معارك الربيع القادم اذا
كانت معارك تصادميه هو نقول ان بيد روسيا
اوراق المواجهه لكن اذا لم نشاهدها في ارض
الميدان
فعلى ارض الواقع الدبابات الغربيه تتميز
وتستطيع ان تحقق انجازات لكن كما قلت هذه
الانجازات لابد من توفر الشروط اللازمه
وهو العدد والتاهيل التدريبي منظومه
الادامه واليه الاستخدام والتوظيف اي
بالدور الدفاعي ام بالدور التعرضي
التكتيكي ام بالدور التعرض العملياتي
لاحظنا انخفاض
قياسه طبعا بما شاء بعناه في الفصول
الاخرى في وتيره المعارك دكتور الدويري
نحن مقبلنا الان على حرب او معركه هجوم
الربيع هل يمكن ان نتوقع ربما شكل اخر او
تطورا اخر في هذه الحرب في فصل الربيع
الان نحن امام يعني طروحات هناك الجانب
الروسي يتحدث عن هجوم الربيع
والجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن هجوم الربيع
وبالتالي ايهما يكون جاهزا لبدء التعرض
ستكون له ما يسمى
زمام المبادعه
وفرض واقع ميداني القوات الروسيه كما قلت
من نظريا ومن حيث السجلات لديها 23 الف
دبابه لكن فعليا لا هي لم تترجم القدرات
على ارض الواقع ولجعت الى فاقنر لحسم
المعارك التي عجز الجيش عن تقديمها الجانب
الاوكراني اذا الوعودات تحققت وهي وعودات
سقيه اذا تحققت تستطيع ان تنفذ تعرض وهذا
التعرض ياخذ عمليه
فكيك ماشيه من الشمال من جهه كار كيف ون
زولا الى الايمان ومن الجنوب من انطلاقا
من خرسون الى جابولوجيا الى
ماريوبل وعمليه تثبيت في الوسط في منطقه
بخموت اكراماتوريس لكن هذا الكلام يجب ان
يكون له ماء يمكنه او يمكن احداثه شكرا لك
يا دكتور دكتور فايز الدويره الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان شكرا لك